everyone is talking about last night's
episode of Jeopardy featuring James
Holzhauer there he is
James holes are you're probably aware
this is a huge deal he's been making a
dramatic run at Ken Jennings all-time
jeopardy winning record of 2.5 2 million
dollars but last night at a critical
moment James fell short yeah he fell
short here is if you haven't seen it the
dramatic moment when he blew his chance
at making history circle TV 16 currently
on TBS he's been on late-night TV since
1993 hosting three different shows Emma
who's Jimmy Buffett no James please come
ooh No Conan O'Brien
[Applause]
he lost it all he lost it all
I think a third of the people in the
crowd think that's real yeah that's too
bad
I've got not one